monsieur blé n'est qu' à félicitations
pour votre réélection
monsieur blé n'est oui bonsoir bonsoir
bonsoir patrice qu'est ce que vous dites
d'abord avant de parler du québec québec
de ceux de cette victoire décisive des
libéraux les gens veulent vraiment le
goût à du changement là manifestement
vous savez chez je m'inspirais ces
derniers jours d'une phrase de la femme
du président obama michelle obama qui
dit toujours que ce qui est important
pour elle c'est pas nécessairement les
sondages des spécialistes les
journalistes sur pop manquer de respect
mais ce qui se passe sur le terrain et
la réalité que je chantais sur le
terrain patrice c'était celle que je
vivais dans les vies dans bellechasse
les etchemins en avoir les aînés les
entreprises en allant au centre d'achat
en allant galeries chagnon en allant par
exemple au resto des listes et à chaque
fois ça sentait bon sur le terrain et ce
soir la perception que j'avais je la
reçois aussi avec beaucoup d'honneur
mais il semble que j'ai eu la plus
grande victoire depuis que je fais de la
politique iv quatrième victoire
alors pour moi c'est ce que je chantais
donc je mettais focus et beaucoup là
dessus et là tu vraiment j'ai eu la
preuve éclatante que ce qui se passe sur
le terrain c'est vraiment ce qui avive
en réalité puisque à nouveau a confié
avec le mandat
c'est le grand paradoxe monsieur blé
n'est parce qu'au québec effectivement
vous est en voie de faire deux fois
mieux et un peu plus même avec 11 en
tête pour les hommes en aviez 5 donc
vous doublez vous doubler le nombre de
sièges potentiel potentiel au québec
puis ailleurs ben c'est vraiment une
défaite quand même important
voyez ça fait plaisir ça va bien le
d'avoir coin ça va bien mais ça va pas
bien ailleurs la lévis est une grande
ville le seuil des 10 grands développer
au québec dit paquet vie est un village
je dis que dans votre coin et vous de
vos restaurants tout ça ça va bien mais
vous voyez comme moi que les libéraux
ont fait une soirée où ils ont remporté
pas mal de compter bref à écouter c'est
sûr que si vous parlez des gains je veux
bien sûr félicité mais mes voisins de la
rive d'en face c'est sûr que je me suis
senti un peu orphelins au cours des
dernières années mais là je suis content
de voir gérard deltell pierre paul-hus
se joindre se joindre à d'autres équipes
évidemment peut-être d'autres personnes
qui qui elles sont toujours dans des
shows de lutte
mais vous savez servir la population
c'est un privilège ce n'est pas un
acquis et ce soir je pense qu'on va
avoir encore les prochaines heures les
prochains jours pour prendre à nous de
ce qu'il se passe non seulement au
québec mais à l'échelle du pays
mais moi je suis très fier en tout cas
du mandat que j'ai reçu et et ma foi on
peut être fier aussi de la place où se
situe le canada aujourd'hui dans le
monde un pays qui fait l'envié du monde
un pays qui a équilibré son budget est
un pays qui s'en va à paris qui a pour
la première fois réduit ses émissions de
gaz à effet de serre merci patrice merci
à monsieur blême et vous avez passé ce
volet merci